what up what up Weezy here what's up
Miss K we cour side right now with
bleach report at the lake the sun game
about to turn up home game
yeah I had a bunch of homework last
night so I didn't even history
[Music]
Spanish the whole time I saw this man
doing the he I thought that was the
whole
like
[Music]
never gave you the
ball what you think about AAR being like
a part like Star what you think about
that part of the Victory and all that I
love Aus one of my favorite players cuz
he's super consistent and reliable I
think him playing in with playing with
the USA this this offseason helped him a
[Music]
lot that consist I kind of thought he
was taller too who n a little bit
thought he was like a 7 fo thought R was
the flag bearer for
like for the Olympics remember d a
[Applause]
a good
pass wanted that ball so bad he just he
stood there with his mouth open he said
the first game was against the Nuggets
right got that ring on that night too
they did that on purpose the crowd say
who's your daddy say one you know that's
the coach said that
D he's good B
that's what that is yeah cuz my new B oh
b
b looks so
dope
[Music]
s you just can't do nothing about it hey
remind me of wmy shop Caleb will over
there where all the way
yeah that was Caleb I holled at him kill
him and say we do V prediction I got
bucks Warriors I did not think about say
the Warriors right now to me step out is
like I used to feel you come Brady out
Pat years where you just like the years
where like that you just just thought
that they just not going to not and then
they be like that's that's how I
be feeling about step like every time
I'm ready to say yeah Steph done is be
right there in the finals
right it's a big big possession
[Applause]
got to let him know who El was that huge
bucket KD is going crazy right now had
to let KD
[Music]
know